the person you're with should make you
so happy like all the time like if they
make you feel bad you know then get rid
of them I've never understood that I
find the concept for the one is the most
arrogant thing in the entire and this is
coming from an incredibly out of good
man but the concept of the of the one is
so narcissistic that not even I can fall
into youth you're telling me if you
believe in the one there's only one
person on this planet that's good enough
for you whine to your [ __ ] man
one-mile radius I can find you a hundred
people who are do you'd say yesterday
yeah yeah who are not only good enough
for me but bear yeah just yeah I am but
we we create this idea and oh my god
when it gets difficult to the work and
why if it's not easy like I think you
know every and I've done those
relationships you know I've been in
those relationships with you the person
makes you feel like [ __ ] and you know
you look at your pension you look at our
grandparents generation because none of
them would get divorced because it was
too inconvenient and [ __ ] being alone
was so taboo and it was you know with
the only way you're ever out of a
relationship as if one of them [ __ ]
died you know back when all of our
ground diets were perverts and they were
perverts they were stalkers how did you
meet your gran oh well she didn't want
me at first and then I [ __ ] water
diving [ __ ] Jesus that's awful that's
horrendous you just lived in a time when
you were just able to stand those
headwear work with flows will I gonna
love you and she worthy and she didn't
have the internet or a phone or tinder
to know that there were options I've
cited the five miles that she inhabited
yeah all right we are grandparents live
through their [ __ ] taste and they
just made in the city
and some of them did stay together for
love but I just think they come out of
[ __ ] World War two
I think five years old and there was
just a week after her alive like I bet
that makes them more of a let's make
loads yeah exactly something I think
[Music]
you